Years ago, my girlfriend was on the phone, talking with her friend Richard, who she just loves. And she's at home, and she's sitting on the couch, and the TV's on. And at some point, he notices the TV in background. I think because occasionally, she would switch channels, which, you know, is kind of a giveaway that maybe you're not paying complete attention to the phone call.
多年前，我女朋友正在电话里和她心爱的朋友理查德聊天。当时她在家里，坐在沙发上，电视开着。聊着聊着，对方注意到了背景里的电视声。我想是因为她偶尔会换台，你知道，这有点泄露了她可能并没有全神贯注在通话上。
So he starts to get annoyed at this, and starts to say to her how rude it is, and how wrong. And her case, her self-defense, completely disarms him, and she totally wins the day with this argument. "I love you, so how can this be wrong?"
于是他开始为此感到恼火，开始对她说这种行为有多粗鲁、多不对。而她的防御方式彻底解除了他的武装，她用这个论点大获全胜。“我爱你，所以这怎么会是错的呢？”
I love you. So if you're mad because you think that I'm watching TV because I don't give a damn about you and what you're saying, please note that this did not detract in any way-- it does not represent any kind of diminishment, any kind of depletion-- of my love. So could it be wrong?
我爱你。所以如果你生气是因为你觉得我看着电视，是因为我不关心你和你说的话，请注意这绝对不会削弱——这不代表任何形式的减少、任何形式的匮乏——我对你的爱。所以这怎么会是错的呢？
Which I have to say completely cracked him up with its brazenness. Under that logic, you can do anything, anything, to the people you love and get away with it. Love is very hard to argue with. You're in an argument with somebody and they say they did it for love-- what are you going to say to that? You just wave the word around, and that's that.
我不得不说，这种厚颜无耻的逻辑彻底把他逗乐了。按照这个逻辑，你可以对你爱的人做任何事，任何事，而且都能逃脱惩罚。爱是很难辩驳的。当你在和某人争吵，而他们说他们这样做是为了爱——你对此能说什么呢？你只是挥舞着这个词，事情就这么定了。
Which brings me into the song "You Are So Beautiful... To Me." You remember that song? Imagine for a second somebody writing that song for you, or singing it to you, and you're hearing the song for the first time. OK. They start off, "You are so beautiful," and you think, OK this is romantic, this is going just great. And then they get to the "to me."
这让我想起了那首歌《You Are So Beautiful... To Me》（你对我而言如此美丽）。记得那首歌吗？想象一下，有人为你写了那首歌，或者为你唱这首歌，而你是第一次听到它。好的。他们开头唱道：“你如此美丽”，你会想，好吧，这很浪漫，这进展得很棒。然后他们唱到了“对我而言（to me）”。
You're not beautiful to everyone. If you were beautiful to everyone, the lyric could stop right there. The song would be called "You Are So Beautiful." There are, in fact, songs exactly like that. "You are so beautiful." But no, no, no. You're not so beautiful in general. You're just so beautiful to me. It's insulting, you know?
你并不是对每个人都美。如果你对每个人都美，歌词在那儿就可以停了。这首歌本该叫《你如此美丽》。事实上，确实有完全那样的歌。但不是，不是，不是。你并不是泛泛而论地如此美丽。你只是“对我而言”如此美丽。这很伤人，你知道吗？
But then, because the entire song is about how huge and complete this love is, what, you're going to argue? The writer or the singer would just say, "I love you. How could this be wrong?"
但随后，因为整首歌都在强调这份爱有多么宏大和完整，怎么着，你还要争辩吗？写歌的人或歌手只会说：“我爱你。这怎么会是错的呢？”
Today on our radio program, we bring you two stories about love. Each story a variation on the idea, "I love you. So how could this be wrong?"
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们为你带来两个关于爱的故事。每个故事都是对“我爱你，所以这怎么会是错的呢？”这一理念的变奏。
Act one of our program. Polly Wants So Much More Than a Cracker. The story of a bird and three small children and what people will put up with for love.
节目第一幕。波莉想要的不只是饼干。这是一个关于一只鸟、三个小孩以及人们为了爱会忍受什么的故事。
Act two. On the Border Between Good and Bad. In that act, we're very excited to have the novelist Russell Banks here on the radio program, reading a short story that we have wanted to get on the air forever. We're finally getting a chance to.
第二幕。善与恶的边缘。在这一幕中，我们非常激动能邀请到小说家拉塞尔·班克斯来到广播节目中，朗读一个我们一直想在节目中播出的短篇小说。我们终于有机会了。
From WBEZ Chicago, This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One. Polly Wants So Much More Than a Cracker.
第一幕。波莉想要的不只是饼干。
When Veronica tells this story, it's a story about love. When she was 17, she saw a bird in a pet store. A macaw, which is a kind of big parrot, brightly colored, with a three-foot wingspan.
当维罗妮卡讲述这个故事时，这是一个关于爱的故事。17岁时，她在宠物店看到了一只鸟。一只金刚鹦鹉，一种大型鹦鹉，颜色鲜艳，翼展有三英尺长。
And I fell in love with her immediately, and you know, I was still in high school, I had no money whatsoever.
我立刻就爱上了她，你知道，当时我还在读高中，我根本没钱。
How expensive was she?
她有多贵？
Well, the price tag on the cage said $1400.
嗯，笼子上的价格标签写着1400美元。
So how long did it take you to pay off the bird?
那你花了多久才付清这只鸟的钱？
It took me about five years to pay her off. Working part time jobs, babysitting.
我花了大约五年时间才付清。做兼职，给人带孩子。
And what did you love about her? What was the thing that drew you to her?
你爱她哪一点？是什么东西吸引了你？
It's hard to describe how it feels to love an animal. But as soon as I saw her face, I just thought she was the most beautiful thing, and I had to have her, and I wanted to see that face every day, and I wanted to care for her. And I didn't know anything about bringing up parrots, or feeding them, or caring for them. I just wanted to take her home like a treasure.
很难描述爱上一只动物的感觉。但当我看到她的脸时，我就觉得她是世界上最美丽的东西，我必须拥有她，我想每天看到那张脸，我想照顾她。我对抚养鹦鹉、喂养它们或照顾它们一窍不通。我只是想把她像宝贝一样带回家。
OK. Fast-forward 23 years. Veronica is now 40 years old, married with two twin boys, Kyle and Cameron, age five, and another boy, Daniel, who's eight. One of the things that she didn't know about parrots when she first saw her macaw is that they can live for 80 years. 80. So every morning she takes the bird, whose name is Gideon, out of her cage, so she can freely wander the house.
好的。快进23年。维罗妮卡现在40岁了，结婚生了两个双胞胎男孩，凯尔和卡梅隆，五岁，还有一个八岁的男孩丹尼尔。她第一次见到金刚鹦鹉时不知道的一件事是，它们可以活80岁。80岁。所以每天早上她都会把那只名叫吉迪恩的鸟从笼子里放出来，让她在屋子里自由走动。
And get into things she shouldn't get into, like a baby. Climbing into laundry baskets and ripping up clothes, and taking the kids' Pokemon cards and ripping them to shreds, and pulling newspapers out of boxes.
然后钻进她不该钻的地方，就像个婴儿一样。爬进洗衣篮撕碎衣服，抢走孩子们的宝可梦卡片撕成碎片，从盒子里拽出报纸。
And so at breakfast, you've got three little kids there.
所以在早餐时，你身边有三个小孩。
The kids will interact with each other, and Gideon will scream as loud as she can over their heads.
孩子们会互相交流，而吉迪恩会在他们头顶尽可能大声地尖叫。
Now let's play a recording of Gideon for people at home.
现在让我们给听众朋友们播放一段吉迪恩的录音。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
It sounds really loud.
听起来真刺耳。
It's intolerable. It's a sound that you don't want to hear.
让人无法忍受。那是一种你不想听到的声音。
It sounds very dinosaur-like.
听起来很像恐龙。
Yeah. Well, you know--
是啊。嗯，你知道——
The word you just use was "intolerable"?
你刚才用的词是“无法忍受”？
It's the most unpleasant sound I think I have ever heard.
我想这是我听过最令人不快的声音。
But you've lived with this sound for 23 years.
但你已经和这个声音相处了23年了。
I've lived with that sound for 23 years. It's in my dreams. It's wherever I go. It's in the kitchen, it's in the dining room, it's in my bedroom. And the kids have grown up with her, so they don't really notice it at first. But after about the fourth or fifth scream, they will start covering their ears and shouting back at the bird, and--
我已经和那个声音相处了23年。它在我的梦里。无论我去哪儿它都在。在厨房里，在餐厅里，在我的卧室里。孩子们是和她一起长大的，所以起初他们并不怎么在意。但在第四或第五声尖叫后，他们就会开始捂住耳朵，对着鸟大喊大叫，然后——
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
Will you stop it, please?
你能停下吗，求你了？
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
Mommy! Will you take Gideon and put him-- her in the tree?
妈妈！你能把吉迪恩带走，把它——把她放到树上去吗？
Now, you taped little interviews with your kids about Gideon. Here's Cameron, who's five.
你录了一些关于吉迪恩的孩子们的采访。这是五岁的卡梅隆。
Do you like having Gideon in the family?
你喜欢吉迪恩在家里吗？
No, really.
不，说真的。
Would you rather that she went somewhere else?
你宁愿她去别的地方吗？
Yeah. All the way to [UNINTELLIGIBLE], to England. Because I don't want her to scream when we're watching TV.
是啊。去[听不清]，去英国。因为我不想她在我们看电视的时候尖叫。
Would you rather have a different kind of pet than Gideon?
你宁愿要一种不同于吉迪恩的宠物吗？
Yeah. A dog that is really nice and doesn't bite and doesn't bark.
是啊。一只真的很乖，不会咬人也不会乱叫的狗。
But do you understand why mommy loves Gideon?
但你明白为什么妈妈爱吉迪恩吗？
Um, no.
嗯，不明白。
This is Kyle, the other twin, also five.
这是凯尔，另一个双胞胎，也是五岁。
One time she just almost bited off my thumb. That kind of scared me.
有一次她差点咬断我的大拇指。那确实吓到我了。
Um, they're terrified of Gideon. If they are approached by her, they'll immediately scream and run away. They won't go near her now.
嗯，他们非常怕吉迪恩。如果她走近他们，他们会立刻尖叫着跑开。他们现在根本不敢靠近她。
And is that because Gideon is in fact a little dangerous? They're right to be a little scared?
这是因为吉迪恩其实有点危险吗？他们有点害怕是应该的？
Well, Gideon's primary objective in life is to be my mate. And so every other person or creature that comes near me is a threat to our relationship. And my children are a very big threat to our relationship, because we have physical contact with each other. And she sees me carrying them and cooking for them and touching them and picking them up. And so she has a desire to kill them, basically. I mean, in the bird world, she would kill a predator or some intrusive love interest.
嗯，吉迪恩生命中的首要目标是成为我的伴侣。所以每一个靠近我的其他人或生物都是对我们关系的威胁。我的孩子们对我们的关系是一个巨大的威胁，因为我们会有身体接触。她看到我抱着他们、为他们做饭、抚摸他们、抱起他们。所以她基本上有一种杀掉他们的欲望。我的意思是，在鸟类的世界里，她会杀死捕食者或任何入侵的情敌。
Now, after your kids were born, and you saw how Gideon reacted to your children, and you saw how your children reacted to Gideon-- they were scared that Gideon bit Kyle-- did it change your feelings about Gideon?
在你的孩子出生后，当你看到吉迪恩对你孩子的反应，以及孩子们对吉迪恩的反应——他们害怕吉迪恩咬了凯尔——这改变了你对吉迪恩的感情吗？
I don't think anything can change my feelings about Gideon.
我不觉得有什么能改变我对吉迪恩的感情。
But if I had a dog that I loved, and you know, then I had a new baby in the house, and the dog was hostile towards the baby, I wouldn't feel the same way about the dog. You know, like I would feel protective of my kid, which I'm sure you did.
但如果我有一只我爱的狗，然后家里有了个新生儿，而狗对孩子有敌意，我就不会对那只狗有同样的感情了。你知道，我会对孩子产生保护欲，我相信你也是。
Well, I do feel protective of the children, and I take certain steps to protect them from her. But I can't stop loving her because of her natural tendency to want to drive away competition.
嗯，我的确对孩子们有保护欲，我也采取了某些措施来保护他们免受她的伤害。但我不能因为她想要赶走竞争对手的天性就不爱她了。
As I said, this is a love story. And though Veronica knows Gideon is driving everybody else who she loves crazy, she loves the bird. The same monogamous feelings that make Gideon mean to everyone else, make Gideon fantastically sweet to Veronica. Gideon watches her every move, cuddles with her, blushes-- Gideon actually blushes when they play together. She is all that Gideon lives for and it's hard to turn away from that.
正如我所说，这是一个爱情故事。尽管维罗妮卡知道吉迪恩把她所爱的每个人都逼疯了，但她就是爱这只鸟。让吉迪恩对别人刻薄的同样那种一夫一妻制的感情，也让吉迪恩对维罗妮卡好得惊人。吉迪恩注视着她的一举一动，依偎着她，脸红——当她们一起玩时，吉迪恩真的会脸红。维罗妮卡是吉迪恩生活的全部，要从中抽身真的很难。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
Thank you, Gideon.
谢谢你，吉迪恩。
Veronica also worries that if she gave the bird away, the bird would die. They mate so fiercely that sometimes when their mate vanishes, that can happen.
维罗妮卡也担心如果她把鸟送走，这只鸟会死。它们交配得如此紧密，有时当它们的伴侣消失时，这种事就会发生。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
I know, Gideon.  It's upsetting.
我知道，吉迪恩。这让人难受。
And then there's this story. When Veronica was 18 and barely owned Gideon for a year, she took Gideon outside like she did every day, and Gideon flew away. Veronica hadn't been careful enough clipping her feathers.
还有这个故事。当维罗妮卡18岁，养吉迪恩刚满一年时，她像往常一样把吉迪恩带到户外，吉迪恩飞走了。维罗妮卡剪断她羽毛时不够小心。
She was wrecked. Every night, Veronica cried herself to sleep. Every day she sat on the roof, watching the sky. After six days, a kid on his way to school spotted the bird.
她崩溃了。每天晚上，维罗妮卡哭着入睡。每天她都坐在屋顶上盯着天空。六天后，一个上学的孩子发现了这只鸟。
And I went quickly, ran to where he said she was, and I saw her in probably the tallest tree. And immediately scaled the tree. Got all the way to the top, which was about, I was up about 50 feet. She was on the end of the branch, all the way out. And so I inched my way out.
我赶紧跑去他说的地点，看到她在大概最高的树上。我立刻爬上了那棵树。爬到了顶端，大概有50英尺高。她站在树枝尽头，离得很远。于是我慢慢挪过去。
And about three quarters of the way out-- I was only a foot away from her-- the branch snapped, and I fell straight down without hitting anything on the way, and just fell 50 feet and landed on my feet on hard ground. And I suffered a multiple compression fracture of my spine and I had a collapsed lung. I should have died, according to the orthopedic surgeon.
在挪到四分之三的路程时——我离她只有一英尺远——树枝断了，我直直地摔了下去，途中没碰到任何东西，就那么摔了50英尺，双脚着地落在了坚硬的地面上。我的脊椎遭受了多处压缩性骨折，肺部塌陷。据骨科医生说，我本该死的。
Do you think the fact that you nearly died trying to save Gideon is one of the things that makes it impossible for you to give Gideon up?
你认为你为了救吉迪恩差点死掉这件事，是让你无法放弃吉迪恩的原因之一吗？
That's something I've thought about, yeah. It's quite possible. I feel like it's brought us closer. It's not a pleasant thing that happened. But I feel like, um-- she would have died out there.
我想过这个问题，是的。很有可能。我觉得这拉近了我们的距离。那不是件愉快的事。但我感到，嗯——如果我在那里，她会死的。
You say that "it brought us closer," but you're the only one who actually understands that you went out and you got injured trying to save Gideon. Gideon doesn't understand that.
你说“这拉近了我们的距离”，但只有你自己才真正明白你是出去并受了伤试图救吉迪恩。吉迪恩并不明白这一点。
No, she doesn't understand that. But I know she understands something. She's very bonded to me. She became so close to me at one point that her hormones produced an egg. And that's something that happens only between couples. So I know she feels something. I don't really need to know much more than that.
不，她不明白。但我知道她明白一些东西。她和我绑定得很深。她曾经一度和我非常亲近，以至于她的荷尔蒙产生了一个蛋。那是只有在伴侣之间才会发生的事。所以我知道她能感觉到什么。我真的不需要知道更多了。
In the end, I think this is only partly a story about Veronica's love for Gideon. It's also a story about her family's love for her, that they put up with the bird.
最后，我想这不仅是关于维罗妮卡对吉迪恩的爱。这也是关于她家人对她的爱，他们忍受了这只鸟。
Now, we all want to believe that the people who love us will at least accept the parts of us that are not so appealing. And in Veronica's case, the unappealing part just happens to have physical form and be a bird. Every day that her kids and her husband put up with that, they prove to her just how much they love her.
我们都想相信，爱我们的人至少会接受我们身上那些不那么吸引人的部分。在维罗妮卡的案例中，那个不吸引人的部分正好有实体，是一只鸟。她的孩子和丈夫每天忍受这一切，就是在向她证明他们有多爱她。
I don't know why you had to buy her. Like, how much bucks was she?
我不明白你为什么要买她。就是说，她要多少钱？
She cost a lot of money.
她花了很多钱。
But how much money?
但具体多少钱？
She cost, like, $1400.
她大概要1400美元。
Whoa. Just for a parrot? Why would they do that? Why?
哇。就为了只鹦鹉？他们为什么要那样做？为什么？
The most remarkable thing, I think, about the phrase "I love you" is how rarely it's used literally to mean I love you. That I have a feeling of love for you. It's used much more often, I think, to mean 100 other things. "Tell me that you love me," or "I need to get off the phone now," or "Things are fine between us, right?" or "Yes, it's fine that we keep the parrot."
我想“我爱你”这句话最了不起的一点在于，它很少被字面意义上地用来表示“我爱你有那种爱你的感觉”。我觉得它被更频繁地用来指代其他一百种含义。“告诉我你爱我”，或者“我现在需要挂断电话了”，或者“我们之间一切都好，对吧？”，或者“是的，我们留下这只鹦鹉没关系。”
Coming up. Yet another way to use the word love. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来。使用“爱”这个词的另一种方式。稍后，芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台将继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, stories of love, and people trying to better understand their own actions in love. We've arrived at act two. On the Border Between Good and Bad.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在节目中，关于爱的故事，以及人们试图更好地理解自己在爱中的行为。我们来到了第二幕。善与恶的边缘。
In this act, we have this short story from Russell Banks, which he was kind enough to read for us. A warning to listeners that he mentions sex in the story. Nothing explicit. Here's Russell Banks.
在这一幕中，我们有来自拉塞尔·班克斯的这个短篇小说，他好心地为我们读了出来。提醒听众，他在故事中提到了性。没什么露骨的。这是拉塞尔·班克斯。
To begin, then, here's a scene in which I am the man and my friend Sarah Cole is the woman. I don't mind describing it now because I'm a decade older and don't look the same now as I did then, and Sarah Cole is dead.
那么，首先，这是一个场景，我是其中的男人，我的朋友莎拉·科尔是其中的女人。我现在不介意描述它，因为我已经老了十岁，现在的样子和当时不一样了，而且莎拉·科尔已经去世了。
That is to say, on hearing this story, you might think me vain if I looked the same now as I did then. Because I must tell you that I was extremely handsome then. And if Sarah were not dead, you'd think I was cruel, for I must tell you that Sarah was very homely. In fact, she was the homeliest woman I have ever known. And I knew her well, because for three and a half months, we were lovers.
也就是说，在听到这个故事时，如果我现在的样子和当时一样，你可能会觉得我很虚荣。因为我必须告诉你，我当时极其英俊。如果莎拉没死，你可能会觉得我很残忍，因为我必须告诉你，莎拉非常平凡。事实上，她是我所认识的最平凡的女人。我非常了解她，因为在那三个半月里，我们是恋人。
Here is the scene. You can put it in the present, even though it took place ten years ago, because nothing that matters to the story depends on when it took place. And you can put it in Concord, New Hampshire, even though that is indeed where it took place, because it doesn't matter where it took place. So it might as well be Concord, New Hampshire, a place I happen to know well, and can therefore describe with sufficient detail to make the story believable.
这是那个场景。你可以把它放在现在，尽管它发生在十年前，因为对故事有意义的东西并不取决于它发生的具体时间。你可以把它放在新罕布什尔州的康科德，尽管它确实是在那里发生的，因为发生在哪里并不重要。所以它也可以是新罕布什尔州的康科德，一个我恰好很了解的地方，因此可以用足够的细节来描述，使故事变得可信。
Around six o'clock on a Wednesday evening in late May, a man enters a bar. The bar, a cocktail lounge at street level with a restaurant upstairs, is decorated with hanging plants and unfinished wood paneling, butcher block tables and captain's chairs, with a half dozen darken and thickly upholstered booths along one wall.
在五月下旬的一个周三傍晚大约六点钟，一个男人走进了一家酒吧。这家酒吧是一家楼下是鸡尾酒吧、楼上有餐厅的场所，装饰着悬挂的植物和未完工的木板墙，有屠夫砧板桌和船长椅，沿墙有一排半打阴暗且厚实软垫的卡座。
Three or four men between the ages of 25 and 35 are drinking at the bar, and like the man who has just entered, wear three piece suits and loosened neckties. They are probably lawyers-- young, unmarried lawyers-- gossipping with their brethren over martinis so as to postpone arriving home alone at their whitewashed townhouse apartments, where they will fix their evening meals in microwave ovens, and afterwards, while their TVs chuckle quietly in front of them, sit on their couches and do a little extra work tomorrow. They are, for the most part, honorable, educated, hardworking, shallow, and moderately unhappy young men.
三四个25到35岁的男人在吧台喝酒，和刚进来的那个男人一样，穿着三件套西装，领带松着。他们可能是律师——年轻、未婚的律师——在马提尼酒间和同僚聊着八卦，以此推迟回到他们空荡荡的白色联排别墅公寓，在那里他们会在微波炉里解决晚餐，之后在电视机对着他们轻声低语时，坐在沙发上明天再做一点额外的工作。他们大体上是体面、受过教育、勤奋、肤浅且略微不快乐的年轻男人。
Our man-- call him Ronald, Ron-- in most ways is like these men, except that he is unusually good-looking, and that makes him a little less unhappy than they. Ron is effortlessly attractive, a genetic wonder. Tall, slender, symmetrical, and clean. He is beautiful the way we usually think of a woman as being beautiful. And he is nice, too-- a consequence, perhaps, of his seeming not to know how beautiful he is to men as well as women, to young people, even children, as well as old, to attractive people, who realize immediately that he is so much more attractive than they as not to be competitive with them, as well as unattractive people.
我们的男人——叫他罗纳德，罗恩——在大多数方面都和这些人一样，除了他异乎寻常的英俊，这使他比他们稍微少了一点不快乐。罗恩拥有毫不费力的吸引力，一个基因奇迹。高大、苗条、匀称且干净。他美得像我们通常认为女人所拥有的那种美。而且他也很好——这可能是一个结果，因为他似乎不知道自己对男人和女人，对年轻人，甚至孩子，对老年人，对那些意识到他比自己吸引人得多而不愿与其竞争的有吸引力的人，以及对不那么有吸引力的人，是多么的迷人。
Ron takes a seat at the bar, unfolds the evening paper in front of him, and before he can start reading, the bartender asks to help him, calling him "sir," even though Ron has come into this bar numerous times at this time of day. Especially since his divorce last fall.
罗恩在吧台找了个位子，在他面前摊开晚报，还没来得及开始看，酒保就问是否需要帮助，称呼他为“先生”，尽管罗恩在这个时间点已经多次来到这家酒吧。尤其是在去年秋天离婚后。
Ron got divorced because after three years of marriage, his wife chose to pursue the career that has interrupted-- that of a fashion designer-- which required her to live in New York City, while he had to continue to live in New Hampshire, where his career got its start. They agreed to live apart until he could continue his career near New York City. But after a few months, between conjugal visits, he started sleeping with other women, and she started sleeping with other men, and that was that.
罗恩离婚是因为结婚三年后，他的妻子选择了追求那份打断了他们的职业——时装设计师——这要求她住在纽约市，而他必须继续住在新罕布什尔州，那里是他的职业起步的地方。他们同意分开住，直到他能在纽约附近继续他的职业。但几个月后，在夫妻团聚之外，他开始和其他女人睡觉，她也开始和其他男人睡觉，事情就是这样。
"No big deal," he explained to friends who liked both Ron and his wife, even though he was slightly more beautiful than she. "We really were too young when we got married. College sweethearts. But we're still best friends," he assured them. They understood. Most of Ron's friends were divorced by then, too.
“没什么大不了的，”他向那些既喜欢罗恩又喜欢他妻子的朋友解释道，尽管他比她稍微漂亮一点点。“我们结婚时确实太年轻了。大学恋人。但我们还是最好的朋友，”他向他们保证。他们理解。罗恩的大多数朋友那时也都离婚了。
Ron orders a scotch and soda with a twist and goes back to reading his paper. He lights a cigarette. He goes on reading. He takes a second sip of his drink. Everyone in the room-- the three or four men scattered along the bar, the tall, thin bartender, and several people in the booths in back-- watches him do these ordinary things.
罗恩点了一杯加柠檬片的苏格兰威士忌苏打水，又回去看报纸。他点了一根烟。继续看。他喝了第二口酒。屋子里的每个人——散落在吧台的三四个男人，高瘦的酒保，以及后排卡座里的几个人——都在看着他做这些平常的事。
He has got to the classified section, is perhaps searching for someone willing to come in once a week and clean his apartment, when the woman who will turn out to be Sarah Cole leaves a booth in the back and approaches him. She comes up from the side and sits next to him. She's wearing heavy tan cowboy boots, and a dark brown suede cowboy hat, lumpy jeans, and a yellow T-shirt that clings to her arms, breasts, and round belly like the skin of a sausage. Though he will later learn that she is 38 years old, she looks older by about 10 years, which makes her look about 20 years older than he actually is.
他翻到了分类广告栏，可能是在寻找愿意每周来打扫他公寓的人，这时那个后来被证明是莎拉·科尔的女人离开了后排的一个卡座，向他走来。她从侧面靠近他，坐在他旁边。她穿着厚重的棕色牛仔靴，戴着深棕色麂皮牛仔帽，穿着凹凸不平的牛仔裤，穿着一件黄色T恤，紧贴着她的手臂、乳房和圆肚子，像香肠的肠衣一样。尽管他后来会得知她已经38岁了，但她看起来老了大约10岁，这使她看起来比他实际年龄老了大约20岁。
"It's not bad here at the bar," she says, looking around. "More light, anyhow. What you reading?" she asks brightly, planting both elbows on the bar.
“这里吧台还不错，”她环顾四周说道。“光线好些，总之。你在看什么？”她明亮地问道，两只手肘支在吧台上。
Ron looks up from his paper with a slight smile on his lips, sees the face of a woman homelier than any he has ever seen or imagined before, and goes on smiling lightly. He feels himself falling into her tiny, slightly crossed dark brown eyes, pulls himself back, and studies, for a few seconds, her mottled, pocked complexion, bulbous nose, loose mouth, twisted and gapped teeth, and heavy but receding chin. He casts a glance over her thatch of dun-colored hair, and along her neck and throat, where acne burns against gray skin, and returns to her eyes, and again feels himself falling into her.
罗恩从报纸上抬起头，嘴唇带着一丝微笑，看到了一个他以前从未见过或想象过的平凡女人的脸，继续轻轻微笑着。他感到自己坠入她那微小、略微斗鸡眼的深褐色眼睛里，回过神来，研究了几秒钟她那斑驳、坑洼的面部皮肤，球茎状的鼻子，松弛的嘴巴，扭曲且有缝的牙齿，以及沉重但后缩的下巴。他扫了一眼她那堆土色的头发，沿着她的颈部和喉咙，那里痤疮在灰色的皮肤上发红，又回到了她的眼睛，再次感到自己坠入其中。
"What did you say?" he asks.
“你说什么？”他问道。
She knocks a mentholated cigarette from her pack and Ron swiftly lights it. Blowing smoke from her large, wing-shaped nostrils, she speaks again. Her voice is thick and nasal, a chocolate-colored voice. "I asked you what you're reading, but I can see now." She belts out a single loud laugh. "The paper."
她从烟盒里敲出一支薄荷烟，罗恩迅速点燃了它。她从硕大的翼状鼻孔中喷出烟雾，再次开口。她的声音厚重而鼻音很重，是一种巧克力色的声音。“我问你在看什么，但我现在能看见了。”她爆发出一阵响亮的笑声。“报纸。”
Ron laughs too. "The paper. The Concord Monitor."
罗恩也笑了。“报纸。《康科德观察家报》。”
He is not hallucinating. He clearly sees what is before him and admits-- no, he asserts to himself that he is speaking to the most unattractive woman he has ever seen, a fact that fascinates him, as if instead he was speaking to the most beautiful woman he has ever seen.
他没有产生幻觉。他清楚地看到了眼前的东西，承认——不，他向自己断言，他正在和一个他见过最没有吸引力的女人交谈，这一事实让他着迷，仿佛他正在和一个他见过最美丽的女人交谈一样。
So he treasures the moment. Attempts to hold it as if it were a golden ball, a disproportionately heavy object which, if he does not hold it lightly, with precision and firmness, will slip from his hand and roll across the lawn to the lip of the well and down, down to the bottom of the well, lost to him forever.
于是他珍视这一刻。试图紧握它，好像它是一个金色的球，一个不成比例的沉重物体，如果不以精确和坚定握住它，它就会从他手中滑落，滚过草坪滚到井边，滚下去，一直滚到底，永远丢失。
To keep this moment here before him, he begins to ask questions. He buys her a drink. He smiles until it seems even to him that he is taking her and her life, its vicissitudes and woe, quite seriously.
为了让这一刻留在眼前，他开始提问。他给她买了一杯酒。他微笑着，直到连他自己都觉得他在非常认真地对待她和她的生活，她的波折和忧虑。
He learns her name, of course, and she volunteers the information that she spoke to him on a dare from one of the two women sitting in the booth behind her. She turns on her school and smiles brazenly, triumphantly, to her friends-- two women, also homely, although nowhere as homely as she-- and dressed like her in cowboy boots, hats, and jeans. One of the women, a blonde with an underslung jaw and wearing heavy eye makeup, flips a little wave at her, and as if embarrassed, she and the other woman at the booth turn back to their drinks and sip fiercely at straws.
他当然了解了她的名字，她主动透露说她是受坐在她身后卡座里的两个女人之一的怂恿才去跟他搭话的。她转向她的学校，对她的朋友们——两个同样平凡的女人，尽管远不如她平凡——露出了厚颜无耻、得意的微笑，她们和她一样穿着牛仔靴、戴着帽子、穿着牛仔裤。其中一个女人，下巴下垂、画着浓重眼妆的金发女郎，对她挥了挥手，仿佛感到尴尬，她和卡座里的另一个女人转回身面对她们的酒，愤怒地用吸管啜饮。
Sarah returns to Ron and goes on telling him what he wants to know. About her job and Rumford Press, about her divorced husband, who was a bastard and stupid and sick, she says, as if filling suddenly with sympathy for the man. She tells Ron about her three children, the youngest a girl in junior high school and boy crazy, the other two boys in high school and almost never at home anymore.
莎拉回到罗恩身边，继续告诉他他想知道的事情。关于她在Rumford Press的工作，关于她离婚的丈夫，那个人是个混蛋，愚蠢而且病态，她说，仿佛突然对那个男人充满了同情。她告诉罗恩关于她三个孩子的事，最小的是个初中生，正迷恋男孩，另外两个男孩在上高中，几乎不再回家了。
She speaks of her children with genuine tenderness and concern, and Ron is touched. He can see with what pleasure and pain she speaks of her children. He watches her tiny eyes light up and water over when he asks their names.
她用真诚的温柔和关心谈论她的孩子，罗恩被打动了。他能看到她谈论孩子时那种愉悦和痛苦。他看着她微小的眼睛亮起来，并在他问起他们的名字时湿润了。
"You're a nice woman," he informs her.
“你是个好女人，”他告诉她。
She smiles, looks at her empty glass. "No. No, I'm not. But you're a nice man to tell me that."
她笑了笑，看着她空空的杯子。“不。不，我不是。但你是告诉我的好男人。”
Ron, with a gesture, asks the bartender to refill Sarah's class. She's drinking White Russians.
罗恩做了个手势，示意酒保给莎拉的杯子续杯。她喝的是白色俄罗斯鸡尾酒。
She asks him about himself, his job, his divorce, how long he has lived in Concord, but he finds that he is not at all interested in telling her about himself. He wants to know about her, even though what she has to tell them about herself is predictable and ordinary, and the way she tells it unadorned and cliched.
她问起他自己、工作、离婚、在康科德住了多久，但他发现他一点也不想告诉她关于他自己的事。他想知道关于她的事，尽管她告诉他的关于自己的事是可以预见的、平常的，而且她叙述的方式平淡且陈词滥调。
He wonders about her husband. What kind of man would fall in love with Sarah Cole?
他想知道她的丈夫。什么样的男人会爱上莎拉·科尔？
That scene, at Osgood's Lounge in Concord, ended with Ron's departure alone after having bought Sarah a second drink and Sarah's return to her friends in the booth. I don't know what she told them, but it's not hard to imagine. The three women were not close friends-- merely fellow workers at Rumford Press, where they stood at the end of a long conveyor belt, day after day, packing TV Guides into cartons.
那个发生在康科德奥斯古德酒廊的场景，以罗恩在给她买了第二杯酒后独自离开，莎拉回到卡座的朋友身边而告终。我不知道她跟她们说了什么，但并不难想象。这三个女人并不是密友——只是Rumford Press的同事，她们在那里站在长长的传送带尽头，日复一日地把《电视指南》装进纸箱。
They all hated their jobs, and frequently after work, when they worked the day shift, they put on the cowboy hats and boots, which they kept all day in their lockers, and stopped for a drink or two on their way home. This had been their first visit to Osgood's, however, a place that prior to this, they had avoided out of a sneering belief that no one went there but lawyers and insurance men.
她们都讨厌自己的工作，经常在下班后，当她们上白班时，她们会穿上牛仔帽和靴子——她们整天把这些放在储物柜里——然后在回家路上停下来喝一两杯。然而，这是她们第一次来奥斯古德，一个在此之前她们因为一种不屑的偏见而避开的地方，觉得除了律师和保险从业者，没人会去那里。
"We'll have to come in here again," Sarah said to her friends, her voice rising slightly. Which they did, that Friday. And once again, Ron appeared with his evening newspaper. After a few minutes, Sarah was once again at his side. "Hi."
“我们得再来这儿，”莎拉对她的朋友们说，声音稍微高了一些。她们确实去了，就在那个周五。罗恩再次带着他的晚报出现。几分钟后，莎拉再次站在他身边。“嗨。”
I said earlier that I'm the man in this story and my friend Sarah Cole, now dead, is the woman. I think back to that night, the second time I had seen Sarah, and I tremble-- not with fear, but in shame.
我早些时候说过我是这个故事里的男人，我已故的朋友莎拉·科尔是那个女人。我回想起那天晚上，我第二次见到莎拉，我颤抖——不是因为恐惧，而是因为羞愧。
My concern then, when I was first becoming involved with Sarah, was merely with the moment. Holding onto it. She talked more easily than she had the night before, and I listened as eagerly and carefully as I had before, again with the same motives-- to keep her in front of me, to draw her forward from the context of her life, and place her, as if she were an object, into the context of mine.
当时，当我刚开始与莎拉产生关联时，我的关注点仅仅是当下。抓住它。她比前一天晚上说得更轻松，我也像之前一样热切而仔细地倾听，带着同样的动机——把她留在眼前，将她从她生活的背景中拉出来，像对待一个物品一样，把她置入我生活的背景中。
I did not know how cruel this was. When you've never done a thing before, and that thing is not simply and clearly right or wrong, you frequently do not know if it is a cruel thing. You just go ahead and do it. Maybe later you'll be able to determine whether you acted cruelly. Too late, of course, but at least you'll know.
我不知道这有多残忍。当你从未做过一件事，而那件事又不是简单清晰地正确或错误时，你经常不知道它是否是一件残忍的事。你只是径直去做。也许以后你才能断定自己是否表现得残忍。当然太晚了，但至少你会知道。
One night several weeks later, Ron meets Sarah at Osgood's, and after buying her three White Russians and drinking three scotches himself, he takes her back to his apartment in his car, a Datsun fastback coupe that she says she admires-- for the sole purpose of making love to her.
几周后的一个晚上，罗恩在奥斯古德见到了莎拉，在买了三杯白色俄罗斯鸡尾酒，自己也喝了三杯苏格兰威士忌后，他开着车带她回到他的公寓——一辆她声称她很欣赏的达特桑快背轿跑车——唯一目的是和她做爱。
I'm still the man in the story and Sarah is still the woman. But I'm telling it this way because what I have to tell you now confuses me, embarrasses me, and makes me sad. And consequently, I'm likely to tell it falsely. I'm likely to cover the truth by making Sarah a better woman than she actually was while making me appear worse than I actually was, or am. Or else I'll do the opposite, makes Sarah worse than she was, and me better.
我仍然是故事里的那个男人，莎拉仍然是那个女人。但我这样讲是因为我现在要告诉你的一些事情让我困惑、尴尬并感到悲伤。因此，我很有可能讲得不真实。我很有可能为了掩盖真相而把莎拉塑造得比她实际更好，同时把自己塑造得比我实际更糟，或者反过来，把莎拉塑造得更糟，把自己塑造成更好。
The truth is, I was pretty-- extremely so. And she was not-- extremely so. And I knew it, and she knew it. She walked out the door of Osgood's determined to make love to a man much prettier than any she had seen up close before, and I walked out determined to make love to a woman much homelier than any I had made love to before. We were, in a sense, equals.
事实是，我很漂亮——极其漂亮。而她则不是——极其平凡。我知道，她也知道。她走出奥斯古德的大门，决心和一个比她近距离见过任何人都漂亮得多的男人做爱，而我走出来，决心和一个比我做过爱的任何人都平凡得多的女人做爱。从某种意义上说，我们是平等的。
No, that's not exactly true. I'm not at all sure she feels as Ron does. That is to say, perhaps she genuinely likes the man, in spite of his being the most physically attractive man she has ever known.
不，那不完全正确。我不确定她是否和罗恩有一样的感觉。也就是说，也许她是真心喜欢这个男人，尽管他是她所见过身体吸引力最强的男人。
Ron unlocks the door to his apartment, walks in ahead of her, and flicks on the lamp beside the couch. It's a small, single bedroom, modern apartment, one of 30 identical apartments in a large brick building on the Heights just east of downtown Concord.
罗恩打开公寓门，走在她前面，按亮了沙发旁边的灯。这是一个小型、单居室、现代化的公寓，位于康科德市中心以东高地的一栋大型砖砌建筑里，那里有30间完全一样的公寓。
Sarah stands nervously at the door, peering in. "Come in! Come in!"  Ron says. She steps timidity in and closes the door behind her. She removes her cowboy hat, then quickly puts it back on, crosses the living room, and plops down in a blonde easy chair, seeming to shrink in its hug out of sight to safety.
莎拉紧张地站在门口，向里窥探。“进来！进来！”罗恩说。她胆怯地走进去，关上了身后的门。她摘下牛仔帽，然后很快又戴了回去，穿过客厅，瘫坐在一张金黄色的休闲椅里，似乎为了安全，在它的怀抱中缩成一团，消失了。
Behind her, Ron, at the entry to the kitchen, places one hand on her shoulder, and she stiffens. He removes his hand. "Would you like a drink?"
在她身后，罗恩在厨房入口，把一只手放在她肩上，她僵住了。他移开了手。“要喝点什么吗？”
"No, I guess not," she says, staring straight ahead at the wall opposite, where a large, framed photograph of a bicyclist advertises in French the Tour de France. Around the corner, in an alcove off the living room, a silvery gray 21-speed bicycle leans casually against the wall, glistening and poised, slender as a thoroughbred racehorse.
“不，我想不用，”她直视着对面的墙壁说道，墙上贴着一张巨大的、带框的自行车手照片，用法语做着环法自行车赛的广告。在客厅旁的一个壁龛里，一辆银灰色的21速自行车随意地靠在墙上，闪闪发光，蓄势待发，像纯种赛马一样纤细。
"I don't know," she says. Ron is in the kitchen now, making himself a drink. "I don't know. I don't know."
“我不知道，”她说。罗恩现在在厨房里，给自己倒酒。“我不知道。我不知道。”
"What? Change your mind? I can make a White Russian for you. Vodka, cream, Kahlua, and ice, right?"
“什么？改变主意了？我可以给你调一杯白色俄罗斯鸡尾酒。伏特加、奶油、卡鲁瓦和冰，对吧？”
Sarah tries to cross her legs, but she is sitting too low in the chair, and her legs are too thick at the thighs, so she ends, after a struggle, with one leg in the air and the other twisted on its side. She looks as if she has fallen from a great height.
莎拉试图交叉双腿，但她坐得在椅子里太低了，她的大腿又太粗，所以一番挣扎后，她最终一只腿悬在空中，另一只腿扭在一边。她看起来好像是从很高的地方摔下来的。
Ron steps out from the kitchen, places one hand on Sarah's shoulder. And this time she does not stiffen, though she does not exactly relax, either. She sits there, a block of wood staring straight ahead.
罗恩从厨房走出来，把一只手放在莎拉肩上。这一次她没有僵硬，虽然她也没怎么放松。她就坐在那里，像一块木头，直视着前方。
"Are you scared?" he asks gently. And he adds, "I am."
“你害怕吗？”他温柔地问。又补充道，“我很害怕。”
"Well, no. I'm not scared." She remains silent for a moment. "You're scared? Of what?" She turns to face him, but avoids his blue eyes.
“嗯，不。我不怕。”她沉默了一会儿。“你怕？怕什么？”她转身面对他，但避开了他那双蓝色的眼睛。
"Well, I don't do this all the time, you know. Bring home a woman I--" he trails off.
“嗯，我不是总做这种事，你知道。带一个我……”他话音渐弱。
"Picked up in a bar."
“在酒吧勾搭上的。”
"No, I mean. I like you, Sarah. I really do. And I didn't just pick you up in a bar. You know that. We've gotten to be friends, you and me."
“不，我是说。我喜欢你，莎拉。我真的喜欢。我不仅是在酒吧把你勾搭上的。你知道的。我们已经成了朋友，你和我。”
"You want to sleep with me?" she asks, still not meeting his steady gaze.
“你想跟我睡觉吗？”她问道，仍然不敢直视他那双坚定的眼睛。
"Yes." He seems to mean it. He does not take a gulp or even a sip from his drink. He just says "yes," straight out and cleanly. Not too quickly, either, and not after hesitant delay. A simple statement of a simple fact. The man wants to make love to the woman. She asked him and he told her. What could be simpler?
“是的。”他看起来是认真的。他没有大口喝，甚至没喝一口。他只是直接、干净利落地说了“是的”。也不算太快，也没有犹豫。这是一个男人想要和一个女人做爱的简单事实。她问他，他就告诉了她。还有什么比这更简单的呢？
"Do you want to sleep with me?" he asks.
“你想跟我睡觉吗？”他问道。
She turns around in the chair, faces the wall again, and says, in a low voice, "Sure I do. But it's hard to explain."
她在椅子里转过身，再次面对墙壁，低声说：“我当然想。但这很难解释。”
"What? But what?" Placing his glass down on the table between the chair and the sofa, he puts both hands on her shoulders and lightly kneads them. He knows he can be discouraged from pursuing this, but he is not sure how easily.
“什么？但是什么？”他把酒杯放在椅子和沙发之间的桌子上，把双手放在她的肩上轻轻捏着。他知道自己可能会被劝阻放弃，但他不确定放弃的难度。
"You and me, Ron-- we're real different." She glances at the bicycle in the corner.
“你和我，罗恩——我们真的很不一样。”她瞥了一眼角落里的自行车。
"A man and a woman," he says.
“一个男人和一个女人，”他说。
"No, not that. I mean different, that's all. Really different. More than you think. You're nice, but you don't know what I mean, and that's one of the things that makes you so nice. But we're different.
“不，不是那个。我是指不同，就是这样。真的很不同。比你想象的更不同。你人很好，但你不知道我指的是什么，那正是让你那么好的原因之一。但我们不同。”
"Listen," she says. "I gotta go. I gotta leave now."
“听着，”她说。“我得走了。我必须现在就走。”
The man removes his hands and retrieves his glass, takes a sip, and watches her over the rim of the glass, as, not without difficulty, the woman rises from the chair and moves swiftly toward the door. She stops at the door, squares her hat on her head, and glances back at him.
男人移开手，取回酒杯，喝了一口，透过杯沿看着她，女人起身后——并不是没有困难——迅速走向门口。她在门口停下，把帽子扶正，回头看了他一眼。
"We can be friends, though. OK?" she says.
“我们可以做朋友，对吧？好吗？”她说。
"OK. Friends."
“好的。朋友。”
"I'll see you again down at Osgood's, right?"
“我会在奥斯古德再见到你，对吧？”
"Oh, yeah. Sure.
“哦，是的。当然。”
"Good. See you," she says, opening the door. The door closes.
“好的。再见，”她说着打开门。门关上了。
The man walks around the sofa, snaps on the television set, and sits down in front of it. He picks up a TV Guide from the coffee table and flips through it. He does not once connect the magazine in his hand to the woman who has just left his apartment, even though he knows she spends her days packing TV Guides into cartons that get shipped to warehouses in distant parts of New England. He'll think of the connection some other night, but by then, the connection will be merely sentimental. It will be too late for him to understand what she meant by "different."
男人绕过沙发，打开电视机，坐下来。他从咖啡桌上拿起一本《电视指南》，翻阅着。他一次都没有把他手中的杂志和刚刚离开他公寓的女人联系起来，尽管他知道她每天把《电视指南》装进纸箱，运往新英格兰遥远地区的仓库。他会在某个其他的晚上想到这种联系，但到那时，这种联系将仅仅是伤感的。他要理解她所说的“不同”是什么意思已经太晚了。
But that's not the point of my story. Certainly it's an aspect of the story-- the political aspect, if you want. But it's not the reason I'm trying to tell it in the first place. I'm trying to tell the story so that I can understand what happened between me and Sarah Cole that summer and early autumn ten years ago. To say we were lovers says very little about what happened. To say we were friends says even less.
但这并不是我故事的重点。当然它是故事的一个侧面——政治层面，如果你愿意的话。但这并不是我最初想要讲述它的原因。我讲述这个故事是为了理解十年前那个夏天和初秋我和莎拉·科尔之间发生了什么。说我们是恋人，对于发生的事情说得很少。说我们是朋友，说得更少。
No, if I'm to understand the whole thing, I'll have to say the whole thing. For in the end, what I need to know was whether what happened between me and Sarah Cole was right or wrong. Character is fate, which suggests that if a man can know and to some degree control his character, he can know, and to that same degree, control his fate.
不，如果要理解整件事，我就必须说出整件事。因为最后，我需要知道的是我和莎拉·科尔之间发生的事情是正确的还是错误的。性格即命运，这暗示着如果一个人能了解并某种程度上控制自己的性格，他就能了解并某种程度上控制自己的命运。
The next time Sarah and I were together, we were at her apartment in the south end of Concord, a second floor flat in a tenement building on Perley Street. I'd stayed away from Osgood's for several weeks, deliberately trying to avoid running into Sarah there, though I never quite put it that way to myself. I found excuses and generated interest in and reasons for going elsewhere after work.
下次莎拉和我在一块时，我们在她位于康科德南端的公寓，那是佩利街一栋廉租房楼里的二楼公寓。我几周来一直远离奥斯古德，故意试图避免在那里碰到莎拉，尽管我从没有这样对自己说。我找借口，产生兴趣和理由在下班后去别处。
Yet I did meet her-- inadvertently, of course. After picking up shirts at the cleaner's on South Main and Perley Streets, I'd gone down Perley on my way to South State and the post office. It was a Saturday morning, and this trip on my bicycle was part of my regular Saturday routine.
然而我确实遇见了她——当然是无意中。在南大街和佩利街的干洗店取回衬衫后，我在去南州街邮局的路上经过佩利街。那是周六早上，这次骑行是我常规周六例行公事的一部分。
I did not remember that Sarah lived on Perley Street, although she had told me several times, in a complaining way. It's a rough neighborhood. Packed dirt yards, shabby apartment buildings, the carcasses of old, half-stripped cars on cinder blocks in the driveways, broken red and yellow plastic tricycles on the cracked sidewalks.
我不记得莎拉住在佩利街，尽管她抱怨式地告诉过我好几次。那是个混乱的社区。堆满泥土的院子，破旧的公寓楼，车道上煤渣砖上老旧、被拆得半光的汽车残骸，破裂的人行道上有破碎的红色和黄色塑料三轮车。
But as soon as I saw her, I remembered. It was too late to avoid meeting her. I was riding my bike wearing shorts and T-shirt, the package containing my folded and starched shirts hooked onto the carrier behind me, and she was walking toward me along the sidewalk, lugging two large bags of groceries.
但一看到她，我就记起来了。要避免见到她已经太晚了。我穿着短裤和T恤骑着自行车，装着我折叠好并上浆的衬衫的包裹钩在我身后的车架上，她正沿着人行道朝我走来，费力地提着两大袋杂货。
She saw me and I stopped. We talked and I offered to carry her groceries for her. I took the bags while she led the bike, handling it carefully, as if she were afraid she might break it.
她看见了我，我停了下来。我们谈了几句，我主动提出帮她提杂货。我拿过袋子，而她推着自行车，小心翼翼地操作着，好像怕把它弄坏似的。
At the stoop, we came to a halt. She leaned the bike against the banister and reached for her groceries. "I'll carry them up for you," I said. I directed her to loop the chain lock from the bike to the banister rail and snap it shut, and told her to bring my shirts up with her.
到了台阶前，我们停了下来。她把自行车靠在扶手上，伸手去拿她的杂货。“我帮你拿上去吧，”我说。我指挥她把自行车上的链锁绕过扶手护栏扣上，告诉她把我的衬衫一起带上去。
"Maybe you'd like a beer?" she said as she opened the door to the darkened hallway. Narrow stairs disappeared in front of me into heavy, damp darkness, and the air smelled like old newspapers. "Sure," I said, and followed her up.
“也许你想喝杯啤酒？”她打开阴暗走廊的门时说道。狭窄的楼梯在我面前消失在沉重、潮湿的黑暗中，空气闻起来像旧报纸。“当然，”我说，跟着她上去。
"Sorry there's no light. I can't get them to fix it."
“抱歉没有灯。我叫不动他们修理。”
"No matter. I can follow along," I said. And even in the dim light of the hall, I could see the large blue veins that cascaded thickly down the backs of her legs. She wore tight, white dot Bermuda shorts, rubber shower sandals, and a pink sleeveless sweater. I pictured her in the cashier's line at the supermarket. I would have been behind her, a stranger, and on seeing her, I would have turned away and studied the covers of the magazines-- TV Guide, People, the National Enquirer. Yet here I was inviting myself into her home, eagerly staring at the backs of her ravaged legs, her sad, tasteless clothing, her poverty.
“没关系。我能跟上，”我说。即使在走廊暗淡的光线下，我也能看到她腿后部浓密流下的巨大蓝色静脉。她穿着紧身的白圆点百慕大短裤，橡胶淋浴凉鞋，和一件粉色无袖毛衣。我设想她在超市的收银台排队。我本会在她后面，一个陌生人，看到她，我会转过身去研究杂志封面——《电视指南》、《人物》、《国民询问报》。然而我却在这里邀请自己进入她的家，渴望地盯着她被摧毁的双腿后部、她悲伤、品味低下的衣服、她的贫穷。
Picture this. The man enters the apartment behind the woman. She waves him toward the table in the kitchen, where he sets down the bags and looks good naturedly around the room. "What about the beer you bribed me with?" he asks.
想象一下。男人跟着女人走进公寓。她示意他走向厨房的桌子，他在那里放下袋子，友善地环顾房间。“你答应贿赂我的啤酒呢？”他问道。
The apartment is cluttered with old, oversized furniture, yard sale and secondhand stuff-- neat and arranged in a more or less orderly way, however-- and the man seems comfortable there. He strolls from the kitchen to the living room and peeks into the three small bedrooms that branch off a hallway behind the living room. "Nice place," he calls to the woman. He studies the framed pictures of her three children, arranged as if on an altar, atop the buffet. "Nice looking kids," he calls out.
公寓里塞满了旧的大型家具，庭院甩卖买来的二手货——整洁地摆放着，以一种或多或少有序的方式，然而——男人似乎在那里很自在。他从厨房溜达到客厅，窥视了客厅后面延伸出来的三间小卧室。“不错的地方，”他向女人喊道。他研究着她三个孩子的带框照片，仿佛在一个祭坛上，摆在餐具柜上面。“挺好看的孩子，”他大声说道。
When he returns to the kitchen, the woman is putting away her groceries, her back to him. "You sure are quiet today, Sarah," he says in a low voice. "Everything OK?"
当他回到厨房时，女人正在收拾杂货，背对着他。“你今天真安静，莎拉，”他低声说。“一切都好吗？”
Silently, she turns away from the grocery bags, crosses the room to the man, reaches up to him, and holding him by the head, kisses his mouth, rolls her torso against his, drops her hands to his hips and yanks him tightly to her, and goes on kissing him, eyes closed, working her face furiously against his. The man places his hands on her shoulders and pulls away, and they face each other, wide-eyed, amazed, and frightened. The man drops his hands and the woman lets go of his hips. Then after a few seconds, the man silently turns, goes to the door, and leaves.
她沉默地从杂货袋转过身，穿过房间来到男人身边，伸手够向他，搂住他的头，亲吻他的嘴，用躯干摩擦他的身体，把手放在他的臀部，将他紧紧拉向她，继续亲吻他，闭着眼睛，脸狂乱地在他的脸上蹭着。男人把手放在她的肩上拉开，他们面对面，睁大眼睛，惊讶又害怕。男人放下手，女人松开了他的臀部。然后几秒钟后，男人沉默地转身，走到门口，离开了。
Sarah appeared at my apartment door the following morning-- a Sunday, cool and rainy. She had brought me the package of freshly laundered shirts I had left in the kitchen, and when I opened the door to her, she simply held the package out to me as if it were a penitence gift. She wore a yellow rain slicker and cap and looked more like a disconsolate schoolgirl facing an angry teacher than a grown woman dropping a package off at a friend's apartment.
莎拉第二天早晨——一个凉爽多雨的周日——出现在我公寓门口。她把我落在厨房的一包刚洗好的衬衫带来了，当我为她打开门时，她仅仅是把包裹递给我，仿佛那是一份忏悔的礼物。她穿着黄色的雨衣和帽子，看起来比一个去朋友公寓送包裹的成年女性更像一个面对愤怒老师的沮丧女学生。
I invited her inside and she accepted my invitation. I had been reading the Sunday New York Times on the coach and drinking coffee, lounging through the gray morning in bathrobe and pajamas. I told her to take off her wet raincoat and hat and hang them in the closet by the door and started for the kitchen to get her a cup of coffee when I stopped, turned, and looked at her. She closed the closet door in yellow raincoat and hat, turned around, and faced me.
我邀请她进去，她接受了我的邀请。我一直在沙发上读《星期日纽约时报》喝咖啡，穿着睡袍和睡衣在灰蒙蒙的早晨里懒散。我叫她脱下湿雨衣和帽子挂在门边的衣柜里，开始去厨房给她拿杯咖啡时，我停了下来，转身看着她。她在黄色雨衣和帽子里关上衣柜门，转身面对我。
What else can I do? I must describe. I remember that moment of ten years ago as if it occurred ten minutes ago. The package of shirts on the table behind her, the newspapers scattered all over the couch and floor, the sound of windblown rain washing the side of the building outside, and the silence of the room as we stood across from one another and watched while we each, simultaneously, removed our own clothing. My robe, her blouse and skirt, my pajama top, her slip and bra, my pajama bottoms, her underpants, until we were both standing naked in the harsh, gray light, two naked members of the same species. A male and a female. The male somewhat younger and slightly less scarred than the female, the female somewhat less delicately constructed than the male. Both individuals, pale-skinned, with dark thatches of hair in the areas of their genitals, both individuals standing slackly as if a great, protracted tension between them had at last been released.
我还能做什么？我必须描述。我记得十年前的那一刻，仿佛它发生在十分钟前。她身后桌上的衬衫包裹，沙发和地板上到处散落的报纸，窗外被大雨冲刷的建筑墙壁声，当我们站在彼此对面看时，房间里的寂静，我们每个人同时移除了自己的衣服。我的睡袍，她的衬衫和裙子，我的睡衣上衣，她的衬裙和文胸，我的睡衣裤子，她的内裤，直到我们都赤裸地站在严酷的灰色光线下，同一个物种的两个裸体成员。一个男人和一个女人。男人比女人年轻一点，稍微少一点疤痕，女人比男人构造稍微没那么精致。两个个体，皮肤苍白，生殖器部位有深色的毛发，两个个体松弛地站着，仿佛他们之间长久以来的巨大紧张感终于得到了释放。
We made love that morning in my bed for long hours that drifted easily into the afternoon, and we talked, as people usually do when they spend half a day or half a night in bed together.
那天早晨，我们在我的床上做爱，漫长的时间轻松地漂进了下午，我们谈话，就像人们在一起在床上躺半天或半夜时通常做的那样。
During the next few weeks, we met and made love often, and always at my apartment. On arriving home from work, I would phone her, or if not, she would phone me, and after a few feints and dodges, one would suggest to the other that we get together tonight, and a half hour later, she'd be at my door. Our lovemaking was passionate, skillful, kindly, and deeply satisfying.
接下来的几周里，我们经常见面做爱，总是在我的公寓里。下班回家后，我会打电话给她，如果不打电话，她会打给我，在几次虚晃和回避后，其中一个会向另一个建议我们今晚聚聚，半小时后，她就会出现在我的门口。我们的做爱充满激情、技巧、亲切，且深层满足。
Then one hot night, a Saturday in August, we were lying in bed atop the tangled sheets, smoking cigarettes and chatting idly, and Sarah suggested that we go out for a drink.
然后一个炎热的夜晚，八月的一个周六，我们躺在床上凌乱的床单上，抽着烟闲聊，莎拉建议我们出去喝一杯。
"Out? Now?"
“出去？现在？”
"Sure. It's early. What time is it?"
“当然。还早。几点了？”
I scanned the digital clock next to the bed. "9:49."
我扫描了一下床边的数字时钟。“9点49分。”
"There. See?"
“那儿。看？”
"That's not so early. You usually go home by 11, you know. It's almost 10."
“那不早。你通常11点前回家，你知道。快10点了。”
"No, it's only a little after 9. Depends on how you look at things. Besides, Ron, it's Saturday night. Or is this the only thing you know how to do?" she said, and poked me in the ribs. "You know how to dance? You like to dance?"
“不，才9点刚过。取决于你怎么看事情。而且，罗恩，这是周六晚上。难道这是你唯一知道怎么做的事？”她说，戳了戳我的肋骨。“你知道怎么跳舞吗？你喜欢跳舞吗？”
"Yeah, sure, sure. But not tonight. It's too hot, and I'm tired." But she persisted, happily pointing out that an air-conditioned bar would be as cool as my apartment, and we didn't have to go to a dance bar. We could go to Osgood's. "As a compromise," she said.
“是的，当然，当然。但今晚不行。太热了，而且我累了。”但她坚持说，高兴地指出空调酒吧会像我的公寓一样凉爽，我们不必去舞厅。我们可以去奥斯古德。“作为一个妥协，”她说。
I suggested a place called the El Rancho, a restaurant with a large, dark cocktail lounge and dance bar located several miles from town on the old Portsmouth Highway. Around 9, the restaurant closed and the bar became something of a roadhouse, with a small Country and Western band and a clientele drawn from the four or five villages that adjoined Concord on the north and east. I had eaten at the restaurant once, but had never gone to the bar. And I didn't know anyone who had.
我建议去一个叫“埃尔牧场”的地方，一家带大型、昏暗鸡尾酒廊和舞厅的餐厅，位于镇外几英里外的老朴茨茅斯公路上。大约9点，餐厅关闭，酒吧变成了一个路边店，有一个小型乡村和西部乐队，客源来自康科德北部和东部相邻的四五个村庄。我曾在餐厅吃过一次饭，但从来没去过酒吧。我也不认识去过那里的人。
Sarah was silent for a moment. Then she lit a cigarette and drew the sheet over her naked body. "You don't want anybody to know about us, Ron. Do you."
莎拉沉默了一会儿。然后她点了一根烟，把床单拉过她的裸体。“你不想让任何人知道我们的事，罗恩。是吗。”
"That's not it. I just don't like gossip, and I work with a lot of people who show up sometimes at Osgood's. On a Saturday night, especially."
“不是那样的。我只是不喜欢八卦，我和很多有时会出现在奥斯古德的人一起工作。特别是在周六晚上。”
"No," she said firmly. "You're ashamed of being seen with me. You'll sleep with me, all right, but you won't go out in public with me."
“不，”她坚定地说。“你为被看见和我在一起感到羞耻。你会和我睡觉，好的，但你不会在公共场合和我一起出去。”
"That's not true, Sarah."
“那不是真的，莎拉。”
She was silent again. Relieved, I reached across her to the bed table and got my cigarettes and lighter.
她再次沉默。感到宽慰，我越过她伸手去拿床头柜上的香烟和打火机。
"You owe me, Ron," she said suddenly as I passed over her. "You owe me."
“你欠我的，罗恩，”当我经过她上方时，她突然说。“你欠我的。”
"I don't know what you're talking about, Sarah. I don't owe you anything."
“我不知道你在说什么，莎拉。我不欠你任何东西。”
"Friendship you owe me, and respect. Friendship and respect. A person can't do what you've done with me without owing them friendship and respect."
“友谊你欠我的，还有尊重。友谊和尊重。一个人如果不欠对方友谊和尊重，是不能和你所做的那样做的。”
"Sarah, I really don't know what you're talking about," I said. "I am your friend. You know that. And I respect you. I do."
“莎拉，我真的不知道你在说什么，”我说。“我是你的朋友。你知道的。我尊重你。我确实尊重。”
"You really think so, don't you."
“你真的这么想，是吧。”
"Yes, of course."
“是的，当然。”
She said nothing for several long moments. Then she sighed, and in her low, almost inaudible voice, said, "Then you'll have to go out in public with me. I don't care about Osgood's or the people you work with. We don't have to go there or see any of them," she said. "But you're going to have to go to places like the El Rancho with me, and a few other places I know, too, where there's people I know. People I work with. And maybe we'll even go to a couple of parties, because I get invited to parties sometimes, you know. I have friends. And I have some family, too, and you're going to have to meet my family. My kids think I'm just going around bar-hopping when I'm over here with you and I don't like that. So you're going to have to meet them, so I can tell them where I am when I'm not at home nights. And sometimes you're going to come over and spend the evening at my place."
她好一会儿什么都没说。然后她叹了口气，用那种低沉的、几乎听不见的声音说：“那你必须在公共场合跟我一起出去。我不在乎奥斯古德或者和你一起工作的人。我们不必去那里或见他们中的任何一个，”她说。“但你必须去像埃尔牧场这样的地方跟我一起，还有其他我知道的几个地方，那里有我认识的人。我一起工作的人。也许我们甚至会去参加几次聚会，因为我有时会被邀请去参加聚会，你知道。我有朋友。我也有一些家人，你也必须见见我的家人。我的孩子们以为我只是在酒吧间逛，当我在这里和你在一起时，我不喜欢那样。所以你必须见见他们，这样当我晚上不在家时，我就能告诉他们我在哪儿。有时你必须过来，在我这边度过晚上。”
Her voice had risen as she heard her demands and felt their rightness until now she was almost shouting at me. "You owe that to me, or else you're a bad man. It's that simple, Ron." It was.
她的声音在她听到自己的要求并感觉到它们的正确性时，变得高昂起来，直到现在她几乎是在对我吼叫。“你欠我的，否则你就是个坏人。就这么简单，罗恩。”确实是。
The handsome man is overdressed. He is wearing a navy blue blazer, taupe shirt, open at the throat, white slacks, white loafers. Everyone else, including the homely woman with the handsome man, is dressed appropriately-- that is, like everyone else. Jeans and cowboy boots, blouses or cowboy shirts or T-shirts with catchy sayings or the names of Country and Western singers printed across the front. And many of the women are wearing cowboy hats pushed back and tied under their chins.
英俊的男人穿着过度。他穿着海军蓝西装外套，灰褐色衬衫，喉咙处敞开，白色长裤，白色乐福鞋。其他人，包括和英俊男人在一起的平凡女人，穿着都很得体——也就是，和大家一样。牛仔裤和牛仔靴，女式衬衫或牛仔衬衫，或印着醒目口号或乡村和西部歌手名字的T恤。许多女人戴着牛仔帽，向后推着并系在下巴下。
The man doesn't know anyone at the bar, or if they're at a party, in the room, but the woman knows most of the people there, and she gladly introduces him. The men grin and shake his hand, slap him on his jacketed shoulder, ask him where he works, what's his line-- after which they lapse into silence. The women flirt briefly with their faces, but they lapse into silence even before the men do.
男人不认识酒吧里的任何人，或者如果他们在聚会里，也不认识屋子里的人，但女人认识那里的大多数人，她很高兴地把他介绍给大家。男人们咧着嘴握他的手，拍他穿着外套的肩膀，问他在哪儿工作，干什么行当——之后他们陷入沉默。女人们短暂地用脸和人调情，但她们甚至在男人们之前就陷入了沉默。
The woman with the man in the blazer does most of the talking for everyone. She talks for the man in the blazer, for the men standing around the refrigerator, or if they're at a bar, for the other men at the table, and for the other women, too. She chats and rambles aimlessly through loud monologues, laughs uproariously at trivial jokes, and drinks too much, until soon she is drunk, thick-tongued, clumsy, and the man has to say her goodbyes and ease her out the door to his car, and drive her home to her apartment on Perley Street.
和穿西装外套男人在一起的女人包揽了大家的大部分谈话。她为穿西装外套的男人说，为站在冰箱周围的男人们，或者如果他们在酒吧，为桌上的其他男人，以及其他女人们说话。她漫无目的地在大声的独白中聊天和散步，对琐碎的笑话大声狂笑，喝得太多，直到很快她喝醉了，口齿不清，笨手笨脚，男人必须替她告别，把她弄出门口带上车，开车送她回家到佩利街的公寓。
This happens twice in one week and then three times the next.
这种情况一周内发生两次，接着下一周三次。
Ron no longer calls Sarah when he gets home from work. He waits for her call, and sometimes, when he knows it's she, he doesn't answer the phone. Usually he lets it ring five or six times, and he reaches down and picks up the receiver. He has taken his jacket and vest off and loosened his tie and is about to put his supper, frozen manicotti, into the microwave oven.
罗恩下班回家后不再打给莎拉。他等待她的电话，有时，当他知道是她时，他不接电话。通常他任由铃声响五六次，然后伸手接起听筒。他已经脱掉了外套和背心，松开了领带，正准备把他晚餐的冷冻意式千层面放进微波炉。
"Hello?"
“喂？”
"Hi."
“嗨。”
"How are you doing?"
“你怎么样？”
"OK, I guess. A little tired.
“还行，我想。有点累。”
"Still hungover?"
“还有宿醉吗？”
"No, not really. Just tired. I hate Mondays."
“不，没有。只是累。我讨厌周一。”
"You have fun last night?"
“昨晚玩得开心吗？”
"Well yes, sort of. It's nice out there at the lake. Listen," she says, brightening. "Why don't you come over here tonight? The kids are all going out later, but if you come over before eight, you can meet them. They really want to meet you."
“嗯，是的，还行。湖边风景不错。听着，”她亮起声音说。“你今晚为什么不过来？孩子们晚点都要出去，如果你八点前过来，你可以见见他们。他们真的很想见你。”
"You told them about me?"
“你告诉他们我的事了？”
"Sure, a long time ago. I'm not supposed to tell my own kids?"
“当然，很久以前了。我不该告诉我的孩子们吗？”
Ron is silent.
罗恩沉默了。
She says, "You don't want to come over here tonight. You don't want to meet my kids. No, you don't want my kids to meet you, that's it.
她说：“你今晚不想过来。你不想见我的孩子。不，你不想让我的孩子见你，就是这样。”
"No, no. It's just, I've got a lot of work to do."
“不，不。只是，我有好多工作要做。”
"We should talk," she announces in a flat voice.
“我们得谈谈，”她平淡地宣布。
"Yes," he says. "We should talk."
“是的，”他说。“我们得谈谈。”
They agree that she will meet him at his apartment and they'll talk, and they say goodbye and hang up.
他们商定她会在他的公寓见他，他们谈谈，于是道别挂了电话。
While Ron is heating his supper and then eating it alone at his kitchen table, and Sarah is feeding her children, perhaps I should admit, since we are nearing the end of my story, that I don't actually know that Sarah Cole is dead. A few years ago, I happened to run into one of her friends from the Press, a blond woman with an underslung jaw. Her name, she reminded me, was Glenda. She had seen me at Osgood's a couple of times, and we had met at the El Rancho once, when I had gone there with Sarah. We were standing outside the Sears store on South Main Street, where I'd gone to buy paint. I had recently remarried, and my wife and I were redecorating my apartment.
当罗恩在加热晚餐然后一个人在厨房桌子吃时，而莎拉在喂她的孩子，也许我该承认，既然我的故事接近尾声，我其实并不知道莎拉·科尔已经去世了。几年前，我恰好碰到了她在印刷厂的朋友之一，一个下巴下垂的金发女人。她的名字，她提醒我，是格伦达。她在奥斯古德见过我几次，我们在埃尔牧场见过一次，当时我是和莎拉一起去的。我们站在南大街西尔斯商店外面，我去那里买漆。我最近再婚了，我和妻子正在重新装饰我的公寓。
"Whatever happened to Sarah?" I ask Glenda. "Is she still down at the Press?"
“莎拉后来怎么样了？”我问格伦达。“她还在印刷厂吗？”
"Jeez, no. She left a long time ago, way back. I heard she went back with her ex-husband. I can't remember his name. Something Cole. Eddie Cole, maybe."
“天哪，没有。她很久以前就离开了，很早以前。我听说她回到她前夫身边了。我不记得他的名字。叫什么科尔。也许叫艾迪·科尔。”
I asked her if she was sure of that, and she said no. She'd only heard it around the bars and at the Press. But she assumed it was true. People said Sarah had moved back with her ex-husband and was living for a while with him and the kids in a trailer in a park near Hooksett, and then when the kids, or at least the boys, get out of school, the rest of them moved down to Florida or someplace, because he was out of work. He was a carpenter, she thought.
我问她是否确定，她说不。她只是在酒吧和印刷厂听说的。但她认为是真的。人们说莎拉搬回去和前夫一起住，有一阵子和他在胡克塞特附近公园里的拖车里带着孩子住，然后当孩子们，或者至少是男孩们，走出学校后，剩下的人搬去了佛罗里达或者别的地方，因为他失业了。她认为他是个木匠。
"He was mean to her," I said.
“他对她不好，”我说。
"Oh, well, yeah. He was a bastard, all right. I met him a couple times and I didn't like him. Short, ugly, and mean when he got drunk. But you know what they say."
“噢，嗯，是的。他是个混蛋，没错。我见过他几次，我不喜欢他。矮、丑，喝醉了就很刻薄。但你知道他们说什么。”
"What do they say?"
“他们说什么？”
"Oh, you know. About water seeking its own level and all."
“噢，你知道。关于物以类聚，人以群分什么的。”
"Sarah wasn't mean, drunk or sober."
“莎拉不刻薄，不管醉酒还是清醒。”
The woman laughed. "Nah, but she sure was short and ugly."
那个女人笑了。“那倒不，但她确实矮小而且丑陋。”
I said nothing.
我什么都没说。
"Hey, don't get me wrong," Glenda said. "I liked Sarah. But you and her-- well, you sure made a funny-looking couple. She probably didn't feel so self-conscious and all with her husband," she said somberly.
“嘿，别误会我的意思，”格伦达说。“我喜欢莎拉。但你和她——好吧，你们看起来确实是一对滑稽的夫妇。她可能在丈夫身边没那么自卑，”她阴郁地说。
"Well. I loved her," I said.
“好吧。我爱她，”我说。
The woman raised one plucked eyebrow in disbelief. She smiled. "Sure you did, honey," she said, and she patted me on the arm. "Sure you did." Then she let the smile drift off her face, turned, and walked away from me.
女人怀疑地扬起一只画过的眉毛。她笑了。“你当然爱，亲爱的，”她说，拍了拍我的胳膊。“你当然爱。”然后她任由笑容从脸上淡去，转身走开了。
When someone you have loved dies, you accept the fact of her death, but then the person goes on living in your memory, dreams, and reveries. You have imaginary conversations with her. You see something striking and remind yourself to tell your loved one about it, and then get brought up short by the fact of her death. And at night, in your sleep, the dead person visits you.
当某位你爱过的人去世时，你接受她死亡的事实，但那个人会继续活在你的记忆、梦境和沉思中。你会和她进行想象中的对话。你看到引人注目的东西，提醒自己要告诉爱人，然后因她死亡的事实而猛然停住。晚上在睡梦中，死去的人会来看你。
With Sarah, none of that happened. When she was gone from my life, she was gone absolutely, as if she had never existed in the first place. It was only later, when I could think of her as dead, I could come out and say it-- "my friend Sarah Cole is dead"-- that I was able to tell this story. For that is when she began to enter my memories, my dreams and reveries. In that way, I learned that I truly did love her, and now I have begun to grieve over her death, to wish her alive again, so that I can say to her the things I could not know or say when she was alive, when I did not know that I loved her.
对于莎拉，这些都没有发生。当她从我的生活中消失时，她完全消失了，仿佛她从来没有存在过一样。直到后来，当我能想到她已经去世，能够走出来并说出它——“我已故的朋友莎拉·科尔”——我才能够讲述这个故事。因为那时她才开始进入我的记忆、梦境和沉思。通过那种方式，我得知我确实爱她，现在我已经开始为她的死感到悲伤，希望她再活过来，这样我就能对她说出那些在她还活着时我无法知道或说出的事情，那时我不知道我爱她。
The woman arrives at Ron's apartment around eight. There was a soft knock at his door. He opens it, turns away, and crosses to the kitchen, where he turns back, lights a cigarette, and watches her. She closes the door. He offers her a drink, which she declines, and somewhat formally, he invites her to sit down.
那个女人在大约八点到达罗恩的公寓。门上轻轻敲了几下。他打开门，转身，走到厨房，转过身，点了一根烟，看着她。她关上门。他递给她一杯酒，她拒绝了，并相当正式地，他邀请她坐下。
She sits carefully on the sofa, in the middle with her feet close together on the floor, as if being interviewed for a job. He comes around and sits in the easy chair, relaxed, one leg slung over the other at the knee, as if he were interviewing her for the job.
她小心地坐在沙发中间，脚在地上靠在一起，仿佛正在参加工作面试。他走过来坐在休闲椅里，放松，一只脚在膝盖处搭在另一只脚上，仿佛他正在面试她。
"Well," he says. "you wanted to talk."
“好吧，”他说。“你想谈谈。”
"Yes. But now you're mad at me. I can see that. I didn't do anything wrong."
“是的。但你现在对我生气了。我看得出来。我没做错什么。”
"I'm not mad at you."
“我没有对你生气。”
They are silent for a moment. Ron goes on smoking his cigarette. Finally she sighs and says, "You don't want to see me anymore, do you."
他们沉默了一会儿。罗恩继续抽烟。终于她叹了口气说：“你不想再见我了，是吗。”
He waits a few seconds and answers. "Yes. That's right." Getting up from the chair, he walks to the silver gray bicycle and stands before it, running a fingertip along the slender crossbar from the saddle to the chrome-plated handlebars.
他等了几秒钟回答。“是的。就是这样。”从椅子上站起，他走向银灰色的自行车，站在它前面，从车座到镀铬的车把，用指尖沿着纤细的横杆划过。
"You're a son of a bitch," she says in a low voice. "You're worse than my ex-husband." Then she smiles meanly, almost sneers, and soon he realizes that she is telling him that she won't leave. He's stuck with her, she informs him with cold precision. "You think I'm just so much meat, and all you've got to do is call up the butcher shop and cancel your order. Well, now you're going to find out different. You can't cancel your order. I'm not meat. I'm not one of your pretty little girlfriends who come running when you want them and go away when you get tired of them. I'm different. I got nothing to lose, Ron. Nothing. So you're stuck with me, Ron."
“你是个混蛋，”她低声说。“你比我前夫还糟。”然后她刻薄地笑了，几乎在嘲笑，很快他意识到她是在告诉他她不会离开。她带着冰冷的精确感告诉他，他被她缠住了。“你以为我只是一块肉，你所要做的就是给肉店打电话取消订单。好吧，现在你会发现不同的。你取消不了订单。我不是肉。我不是你那些想要时就跑过来，当你厌倦时就走开的漂亮小女朋友。我是不同的。我一无所有，罗恩。什么都没有。所以你被我缠住了，罗恩。”
She sits back in the couch and crosses her legs at the ankles. "I think I will have that drink you offered."
她坐在沙发里，脚踝处交叉双腿。“我想我要喝你提供的那杯酒。”
"Look, Sarah. It would be better if you go now."
“听着，莎拉。你现在走比较好。”
"No," she says flatly. "You offered me a drink when I came in. Nothing's changed since I've been here, not for me and not for you. I'd like that drink you offered," she says haughtily.
“不，”她平淡地说。“你刚进来时提供了酒。我在这里时什么都没变，对我来说没变，对你也一样。我想要你提供的那杯酒，”她傲慢地说。
Ron turns away from the bicycle and takes a step toward her. His face has stiffened into a mask. "Enough is enough," he says through clenched teeth. "I've given you enough."
罗恩转过身离开自行车，向她走了一步。他的脸僵硬成了一个面具。“适可而止，”他咬着牙说。“我已经给了你够多了。”
"Fix me a drink, will you, honey?" she says with a phony smile.
“帮我倒杯酒，好吗，亲爱的？”她假笑着说。
Ron orders her to leave. She refuses. He grabs her by the arm and yanks her to her feet. She starts crying lightly. She stands there and looks up into his face and weeps. But she does not move toward the door, so he pushes her. She regains her balance and goes on weeping. He stands back, and places his fists on his hips, and looks at her. "Go on. Go on and leave, you ugly bitch," he says to her. He says the words again, almost tenderly. "Leave, you ugly bitch."
罗恩命令她离开。她拒绝了。他抓住她的胳膊把她拉起来。她开始轻声哭泣。她站在那儿抬头看着他的脸哭泣。但她没有走向门口，于是他推了她一下。她恢复了平衡继续哭泣。他退后一步，把拳头放在臀部，看着她。“走吧。走吧，离开这儿，你这丑陋的婊子，”他对她说。他又重复了那些话，几乎是温柔地。“离开，你这丑陋的婊子。”
Her hair is golden, her brown eyes deep and sad, her mouth full and affectionate, her tears the tears of love and loss, and her pleading, outstretched arms, her entire body, the arms and body of a devoted woman's cruelly rejected love.
她的头发是金色的，棕色的眼睛深邃而悲伤，嘴巴丰满而充满感情，她的眼泪是爱与失落的眼泪，她那恳求的、伸出的双臂，她整个身体，都是一个深情女人被残忍拒绝的爱的双臂和身体。
A third time he says the words. "Leave me now, you disgusting, ugly bitch."
他第三次说了那些话。“现在离开我，你这令人作呕的、丑陋的婊子。”
She is wrapped in an envelope of golden light, a warm, dense haze that she seems to have stepped into as into a carriage. And then she is gone and he is alone again.
她被包裹在金色的光芒中，一层温暖、浓重的迷雾，她似乎像进入马车一样走进了它。然后她消失了，他又回到了孤独之中。
He looks around the room, searching for her. Sitting down in the easy chair, he places his face in his hands. It's not as if she has died. It's as if he has killed her.
他环顾房间，寻找她。坐在休闲椅里，他双手捂脸。这不是她死了。而是仿佛他杀了她。
Russell Banks, reading from his short story "Sarah Cole: A Type of Love Story." The full, unedited version of this story is in his collection The Angel on the Roof.
拉塞尔·班克斯，朗读他的短篇小说《莎拉·科尔：一种爱情故事》。这个故事的完整、未删节版本在他的文集《屋顶上的天使》中。
You know you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife. with other Public Radio programs, bestselling books, even the New York Times , all at audible.com.
你知道你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频。和其他公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》一起，都在audible.com。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. You know, you don't want to be around him when he's mad. Listen to him.
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚。你知道，当他生气时你不会想在他周围。听听他。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫声]
Torey.
托里。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。